(upbeat music)
(loud bang)
- Hi, Adam.
Good summer?
- Shut the fuck up, Tromboner.
Give me what you got.
Think you forgot something.
- It's just a pencil case.
- Don't give a fuck
about your pencil case,
Curly Whurly.
- Common man! Not my Curly Whurly.
- Give me that Curly Whurly
or I will break your face.
- He still calls me Tromboner.
It's been four years.
Four years!
Do you recon his brain is so small
because his dick is so big.
- That's a myth.
- It's not.
- You're five minutes past curfew.
- Sorry dad,
lost track of time.
- Don't let it happen again.
- Kay why can't we just get back together?
- Because you're embarrassing.
Sorry Adam.
- Dad it wasn't...
we were just having a bit of fun.
- Take that stuff off your
face before your mother sees.
- We've been friends since
we were nine years old
and you've abandoned me
for someone you've known
for five seconds.
- Maybe,
I am learning from my brave son.
- Dad (laughing).
- [Adam] What the fuck did
you come as Tromboner? A girl?
- [Eric] What do you want Adam?
- I'm going to fucking kill you.
- [Eric] Okay,
are you going to do it now or later?
Because I'm ready when you are.
- It's coming.
- Okay.
So later then.
Great!
- I hate you!
(loud bang)
(crash)
(thud)
- Get off!
Get off me!
(spits)
sorry.
sorry. I didn't--
(spits)
- How do you like it?
- I don't.
- Yeah,
didn't think so.
(dramatic music)
(kissing)
(heavy breathing)
(gravel crunching)
- Adam, how you doing?
- Hey man.
- Hey, you all right?
- Yeah.
- Out!
(rifles thud)
- Slope arms!
(stomp)
- I'm Rahim.
- Um I'm Eric.
- Goodbye Eric.
- Bye.
- Right, it's not my weed,
they wanted to get my expelled
because they're, puffs.
So.
- Yes,
quite a lot of bizarre
puffs in this institution.
- That was your last chance
at a formal education.
If you put one foot out of line
you won't have a roof over your head.
Understood?
- I was wondering if you'd like
to go out with me sometime?
- What? Like on a date?
- Yeah. Maybe tonight?
- Yes, sure.
Cool, I'll be there.
- Ah,
this is me.
Do you want to come in
and see where I live.
- Yes (laughing).
- Sexy right? I live above a shop.
(bell chimes)
- When did you get back?
- None of your business. Tromboner.
- Do you guys know each other?
- We used to go to school together.
Um, do you know what,
um
it's a bit late
and I need to get home.
Sorry.
- Okay.
(thud)
- You coming?
(shattering)
- (laughs)
- Way.
(laughing)
- Now that was great.
What was military school like?
- Better than being back home.
- I know you hate it at home, but
I'm kind of glad you're back.
- I've gotta go.
- I was thinking
that maybe you want to be my boyfriend.
No pressure okay?
You think about it.
- He bullied you!
For years!
Eric he's a horrible person.
- Yeah, but people can change.
- If he's changed
then why is he making you
sneak around at night.
- It's romantic.
- (Otis scoffs)
- You don't like being the
one left behind for a change.
- No Eric this is about
you being so self hating
that you'd let yourself fall for someone
who literally treats you like shit.
- Don't therapize me Otis.
You don't know what my reality is.
- Okay.
- I would like to be your boyfriend Rahim.
(laughing)
- You stopped coming to the window.
- Yeah, I did.
- What did I do wrong?
- You bullied me for years, Adam.
You made me feel unsafe for years.
You were one of the main
reasons I was unkind to myself
and I'm suppose to believe
that you suddenly changed.
You're full of shame man
and I can't be in that place any more.
I had to work really hard to love myself
and I won't go back to
hating things about me again.
- I'm scared.
And I think I'm bisexual.
- Are you all right?
You can't even hold my hand.
Rahim can hold my hand.
- I feel like everyone hates me.
- Well, it's kind of hard to like someone
who doesn't like themselves.
Your thoughts are very loud man.
- That boy is not right for you.
- You don't think any boy is right for me.
- It's not him, it's you.
You act like a different
person when you're around him,
like you're trying to be
something that you're not.
He doesn't make you sparkle.
(door shuts)
- It's a forest full of dicks man.
It's full of dicks.
(laughing)
I didn't mean what I said at the party,
about people not likely you.
- I'm very easy to not like, they are.
I understand I hurt you.
- Kay.
- Just wanted you to know that.
- I know you like my boyfriend.
You make him laugh,
he doesn't laugh that way with me.
- You have to let the people you love
know that you love them.
Even if it causes you
a great deal of pain.
- Boy,
sounds awful.
- Because you're alive.
- I have to go.
- Stop!
- (crowd gasps)
- I have something to say!
- What are you doing?
- Eric I feel
Eric I feel I have
something to say to you.
I want to hold your hand.
- Say it again.
- Please?
Will you hold my hand?
(dramatic music)
- Yes.
(cheering)
- Play the next one now.
(clapping and cheering)
- Go through the vagina,
through the vagina.
- Adam,
this is my mom and my sisters.
- Lovely to meet you Adam.
- Hi.
- Lovely to meet you.
- Uh I'll be right back.
- Rahim.
Rahim I'm sorry, I didn't-
- Don't apologize. It makes it worse.
Be careful, he can hold your hand
but I'm not sure he can catch you.
(dramatic music)